you have a project that ultimately
didn't move forward for whatever reason
even though it was close to production
I'm actually surprised at how long it
took me to think of it and I was like oh
yeah I was gonna direct a Star Wars
movie but it took me like literally like
a minute because I I couldn't I being
serious you really close to you weren't
close to scenery you were no we were we
were you know art and and and right he
was a development thing it was a script
developing and and you know I guess the
the lesson from it is you know I'd
always I've been very fortunate you know
and then the films that I've directed
I've I've always really the path that I
that I wanted to follow and the path
that you know every everyone involved
wanted to follow was the same and it's
it's totally possible for people to see
two totally different paths through the
woods so you know that that was just an
experience that obviously you can
imagine you know as all of these things
like you can get to the point of being
you know traumatic when there's
something that you care about that much
and you've invested that much in it but
that's one of the things that you accept
when you when you take on any any role
in film and especially when you become a
storyteller that they're going to be
heartbreaks you know there's going to be
crushing disappointments and then
there's going to be there's going to be
victories and hopefully they'll balance
out in the end I didn't get to have a
table read with Tom Cruise and Brad Pitt
that's pretty awesome I do I actually
hold on a second I got something cool so
this is one of the my son and I designed
a ship X we were designing ships and one
of the two - I have two ships one of
them is at the theme park Disneyland
this is the other one it only exists in
this 3d model and for Christmas it's
called the timer otter it's it does this
and for Christmas the guys painted it
for me so I only had this in a 3d model
and now this is the only one in the
world and it's an amazing memory for me
it's something that you know when I got
to do something that was an incredible
experience and just from start to finish
that I was able to to make a Star Wars
ship with my son